en huit ans d'existence la toute jeune
marque de cet effet une réputation
internationale avec ses vernis naturel
et avait décidé de se lancer dans le
rouge à lèvres normalement ça aurait dû
être une très belle année pour nous de
lancement c'était dans notre idée
d'avoir les coordonnées pour les lèvres
de pouvoir va faire un petit peu les
ongles les lèvres et puis d'approcher
une beauté non toxique et bienveillante
global bon bain sous le masque le rouge
à lèvres c'est sûr c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué grand magasin parisien
fermé puis port du masque imposé il a
fallu rebondir et mettre en avant les
formules innovantes
imaginé par les créateurs de la marque
vous êtes sur une base de mangue de
grenade
henri chèque de l'huile d'argan aussi
donc là ça va vraiment être de
l'hydratation pour prendre soin des
lèvres
[Musique]
c'est des choses qui sont naturels c'est
byzantin donc les ici on
on est content de pouvoir présenter des
choses qui sont locales et c'est super
la mise en avant du soin et de la
composition totalement innovante s'est
donc imposé que les soul masquer un beau
mais quand même hein parce qu'on va
continuer à aller de rater donc c'est
vrai qu'on aurait tendance de croire que
le rouge à lèvres savoir un petit peu
moins bien alors c'est peut-être pas la
meilleure en effet saison mais on se
rend compte que les femmes elles ont
quand même envie de rester féminine avec
trente emplois dont peut-être pour la
logistique qui se fait depuis besançon
dans le plus grand secret la marque
entend bien tirer son épingle du jeu
les plus grands noms de la haute couture
adhèrent déjà malgré la crise moi je
veux d'abord qu'on choisisse la couleur
la belle couleur c'est du plaisir c'est
de la mode puis à prince du monde est
super en plus la cerise sur le gâteau
c'est non toxique en plus voilà on est
français en plus c'est familial en plus
c'est bisontin aussi mais celle la
cerise sur le gâteau et comme un pied de
nez aux masques couvert de traces l'envi
de couleurs et de glamour pourrait bien
être une façon de résister au
catastrophisme et aux contraintes
imposées par le virus
[Musique]